the Joe Rogan experience now one of the
big issues it's in the news right now is
the trade war with China I mean this is
a huge issue and it's made me dive into
a lot of really weird stuff with Huawei
and with Chinese government's involved
in in various corporations and it's a
hard concept to grasp for the average
American citizen that the corporations
in China are an extra-big connected to
the communist government and that this
is they work hand in hand they do the
bidding of the government they work
together even though they are profitable
radically profitable they also do things
specifically at the bidding of the
government including inserting [ __ ] that
can allow people to spy on people which
is why they're banning Huawei devices
and yeah this is it all comes back back
to what you were talking about earlier
to an intellectual copyright with in
terms of pharmaceutical drugs the same
thing can be said about electronics I
mean there's entire Apple stores in
China that have nothing to do with Apple
they don't even yeah they just make
their own stuff and call the Apple stuff
thieves yeah it's very strange right
what what do you think about this sort
of like tug of war that's going on right
now that we're seeing play out publicly
well I I think that Chinese deserve
every bit of it for all the reasons you
just stated their intellectual property
theft is rampant and it has been for a
very long time and we've been in this
position where our business community
doesn't want to bash them too bad
because they want that market to be
opened up and they'll know and they'll
be very conciliatory to whatever the
Chinese want in order to get openings to
that market and you know this is the in
Trump is the first president it's really
saying no this is enough is enough I've
and so while I think that I'm starting
to everybody think that's because he's
the first person that actually has a
background in business like real big
business that could be it
that could be it I don't I don't know
why exactly but I know he's doing it so
like that could he's been talking about
this for a very long time yes yes
talking about this in 90s he was yeah
and and I'm not overly sympathetic to
trade Wars especially with our allies
and I was I was happy to see us getting
to a deal with Canada in Mexico I don't
see a point in in strong-arming them but
with China I'm much more sympathetic to
it and I think that that should largely
be bipartisan and you don't even see
Democrats slamming Trump too much for
this and but there are consequences and
so I would like the president to be more
forthright about listen we are gonna
feel some pain too because when you
implement tariffs you're affecting
people's supply chains when you do that
you're hurting American businesses too
there has to be a reason for that okay
and the reason is the Chinese are bad
actors and we are we are in sort of an
economic cold war with them the Chinese
think in 50 year terms we think in
four-year terms they have a huge
advantage in the sense they viewed an
advantage that they can prop up their
businesses and and and and put forth
their belt and Road initiatives and made
in China 2025 I think is won't be
getting that wrong but you know they can
they can manipulate public opinion to
encourage those statist policies and
there's disadvantages to that too it
means they're much less dynamic the fact
that they steal everything means they'll
never be competitive they're not truly a
great you know great nation the way
they're making themselves out to be
because they're thieves and and I think
we should point that out but we are in
this cultural war with them we are in
this economic you know cold war with
them and that's that's that's nothing
new
but it is coming to the forefront and so
we've got to be careful I would prefer
you know we do we take fights to the WTO
we actually have a good history of being
successful in the WTO against the
Chinese and we go after singular
companies like Huawei that would that
would I would like to see that you know
again I'm sympathetic to the tariffs but
they do hurt us
they hurt us there are a lot of people
in my district Texas is a good
competitive market we do well when
there's free competition and so we tend
to want more free trade and more free
competition because we know we can
handle it so so when there's not that it
can tend to hurt because we have very
complex supply chains throughout the
world and then take note of that well it
seems like a game of chicken almost yeah
that's what it seems like back and forth
it's like who's gonna blink it is like
that the
the crazy the international business
gets done we'd seen that so bizarre to a
dummy like me sit on the sidelines come
yeah these guys doing and there's just a
playbook that tells you exactly how you
should go forth with this there's just
you know and and so there this isn't and
it makes it harder you've got to take a
lot of things into account and and have
a good end goal in mind and I think I
think we could do a better job of having
that but but in the end I think I'm as
it holistically I'm more sympathetic to
being hard on the Chinese